[Music]
let's say you're in London you need to
get from the London Eye to Buckingham
Palace
taxi Palace please we would leave one
hour right Belvedere Road left it chilly
streets oh wait you know the whole route
already what we have - all London black
cab drivers have to have completed their
knowledge we need to know all the
straights of modes in London to provide
that service okay let's go see with the
Queen lips
[Music]
London is famous for its black taxis you
need to get to somewhere no sweat
because every black cabbie has to pass
insanely hard test known as the
knowledge like this guy hello my name is
Peter Allen I've been in London taxi
driver for nine years
okay all knowledge is the test that you
have to pass in order to become a London
taxi driver it's the toughest taxi test
in the world the first thing you have to
do is learn what's called the blue book
as of cab driver it's your Bible you
have to learn 320 routes around London
so that's 640 quarter of a mile areas
you have to learn 25,000 streets and
roads within a six-mile radius or
Trafalgar Square in London you have to
learn every single point of interest
place of interest apartment building
housing estate lease station lost
synagogue is a few moments later
burnisher come on a show at club our
restaurant everything anyway we're a
pain passion you might want to go okay
then let's go to the exam center my name
is Katie channels and I'm the knowledge
of London manager so the exams are
several phases of oral appearances it's
basically an interview type situation
where you describe the streets and roads
attempting to use the shortest distance
between point a and point B at the
beginning we might ask them the name of
a theater where that theater is and by
the end of their knowledge we expect
them to know boys actually showing at
that theater what on average it takes
two to four years to learn the knowledge
the best way to study is to go out onto
the streets on a scooter
isn't that right at us my name is a bass
actor who they studied knowledge for
about four and a half years now and my
next appearances in about three weeks
time it's like a full-time job you wake
up in the morning go out on your by a
couple of hours come to the College
study study study here so it wasn't
sleeping over studying as well
yeah one in five who attempt the
knowledge actually pass that's the same
success rate as a u.s. Navy SEAL GPS and
Sat Navs are banned in the exam but why
not use them on the streets my GPS is
here and if we get somewhere and we see
a roads closed we need to say right
that's closed but I know if I go left
here that we
take me there I'll go right here that
would take me there we need to be able
to do all that as well as having a
conversation with the person in the back
and solving the world's problems at the
same time Leicester Square to Big Ben
please so you'd leave Leicester Square
by Irving straight to turn right into
Charing Cross round go forwards
[Music]
you